HERE ARE CHAIR OF THE ASSEMBLY
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE AND I
WANT TO GET BACK TO BUSINESS
SO. WILL START AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE AND ASSUMING WE
CAN GET A QUORUM PRETTY QUICK
WILL TAKE ROLE BUT- IN TERMS OF.
THERE ARE LIKE TO. TURN OVER
THE CHAIR FRAZIER TO THE
PRESENT THE TRANSPORTATION BILL.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK
YOU FOR SUPPORTING OUR ON THE
OMNIBUS BILL ON CONSENT EARLIER
THIS YEAR. THE CHANGES MADE TO
THE BILL UP FOR YOUR MEANT TO
CORRECT A LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT
MADE IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN. AS
YOU REMEMBER MAY REMEMBER FROM
THE CONVERSATION EARLIER THIS
YEAR ON SB SIX TWENTY FIVE. IN
VIRTUALLY MADE IT LEGAL FOR
PASSENGERS. OF A LIMOUSINE OR
PARTY BUS TO CONSUME CANNABIS
WHEN THE LEGISLATURE PASSED
CENTER HILLS SB SIXTY FIVE TO
PROHIBIT. CONSUMPTION OF
CANNABIS BY A DRIVER THE
PASSENGERS IN THE VEHICLE. I
SUPPORTED SENATOR SB SIX TWENTY
FIVE WHICH SOUGHT TO CLOSE THAT
LOOPHOLE BY ALLOWING FOR THE
CONTINUE CONSUMPTION OF
CANNABIS AT THE DRIVER. WAS
SEALED OFF FROM THE PASSENGERS.
ACTUALLY THE CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY
PATROL CAME IN LATE OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL. OVER THE
IMPLEMENTATION ISSUES SENATOR
HILL MOVE THE BILL TO THE
INACTIVE FILE AS A RESULT IN
CITIES PLEASE OPPOSITION. I'M
COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH
CENTER HILL AND YOU NEXT YEAR
ON FINDING A SOLUTION ON SB SIX
TWENTY FIVE. UNTIL THEN THE
MINISTER AB EIGHTEEN TEN KEY TO
THE LEGISLATIVE INTENT OF SB
SIXTY FIVE AND PROHIBIT THE
CONSUMPTION OF CANNABIS IN ALL
VEHICLES. I'LL ASIAN IS ONLY AN
INFRACTION. I AM JOHN LEVEL
HERE TODAY TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT. OKAY WE HAVE SPEAKERS
IN FAVOR PLEASE THANK YOU JOHN
LEVEL ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA NARCOTICS OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION AND A WHOLE HOST OF
OTHER LAW ENFORCEMENT GROUPS I
WON'T TAKE THE COMMITTEES THAT
WE SUPPORT THIS IS A GOOD SENSE
CLEAN UP MEASURE. AND WE JOIN
WITH FOR LITERALLY EVERYONE
ELSE IN WORKING TO IMPLEMENT
AND FIND SB SIX TWENTY FIVE
SOLUTION WHICH WE SUPPORTED
AFTER IT CLEARED YOUR
COMMITTEES ARE. OKAY. OTHER
SPEAKERS PLEASE THE SERVICE
CHAIR MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS
GREG COOK REPRESENT A GREATER
CALIFORNIA LIVERIES SOCIAIS XIN
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL. OKAY
THE OTHER SPEAKERS FAVOR WE
HAVE A POST SPEAKERS A POST
PLEASE. FOR YES. AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE
MEMBERS AMY JENKINS ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA CANNABIS
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION I'M WE DO
APPRECIATE THE COMMITMENT MADE
BY THE AUTHOR TO YOU TO WORK
WITH THE INDUSTRY WE WERE VERY
STRONG SUPPORTERS OF SB SIX
TWENTY FIVE WE DO RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL TODAY WE DO
FEEL THAT THERE ARE VERY
LIMITED OPTIONS FOR THE
CANNABIS INDUSTRY AND ITS
CONSUMERS TO SAFELY CONSUME
CANNABIS WE WERE DISAPPOINTED
SB SIX TWENTY FIVE WAS TABLED
AND JUST GENERALLY OPPOSE THESE
TYPES OF PROHIBITIONS BUT DO
APPRECIATE THE COMMITMENT MADE.
THANK YOU. OUR OTHER PUT.
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE
ANYBODY HAVE QUESTIONS. AND.
ANY FURTHER COMMENTS FROM THE
AUTHOR. IS RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE OKAY. IN THANK YOU
WILL WILL WAIT HERE TILL WE GET
A QUORUM WILL HAVE A VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER CLOSE. SEVEN
ONE MORE. THANK YOU. OKAY WE'LL
GET ONE MORE CALL THE ROLL.
CALL OF ONE. THE GUINNESS
CENTER. TO QUOTE WILL CALL THE
ROLL IN AND TAKE A VOTE SINCE
WE GOT A CORE
. WE HAVE A
CARAMEL KALRA PLEASE. SENATOR
ABOUT HERE PRESENT BATES. IT'S
PRESENT ALI DOT GALGIANI
MCGUIRE. WHERE PRESENT MORALE.
BURL PRESENT ROTH PRESENT RUBIO.
YOUR PRESENT SKINNER STONE
NUMBER YEAH I'M BURKE PRESENT
CASKEY. OKAY WE HAVE A QUORUM
WE HEARD TESTIMONY ON THOSE SO
BILL. AND IS IT ASSEMBLY BILL.
ONE EIGHT ONE ZERO I RECOMMEND
APPROVAL OF THE MOTION. AND ANY
FURTHER SPECIAL ORAL PLEASE.
THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTEEN
TEN BY THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE
ON TRANSPORTATION THE MOTION IS
THAT THE MEASURE BE RETURNED TO
THE SENATE FLOOR FOR
CONSIDERATION REBEL HI. HI
BATES HI HI DOLLY DODD GALGIANI.
BUT CRIER PRESENT MORALE. FIVE
ROSS ROSS I RUBIO. I SKINNER
STONE STONE AYE AMBER. NUMBER I
WILL COST ME. OKAY WE HAVE A
VOTE SO. LEAVE THE ROAD FOR
THREE MINUTES. FOR OTHER
MEMBERS AND THEN WE'LL ADJOURN.
WE GOT THREE MINUTES AT THE
TIME
. ONE MORE THESE FIRST BILL
YEAH OKAY
. ASSEMBLY BILL
EIGHTEEN TEN BY THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON TRANSPORTATION THE
MOTION IS THAT MEASURE BE
RETURNED TO THE SENATE FLOOR
FOR CONSIDERATION SIR DOLLING
DON GALGIANI SKINNER. SKINNER I
WILL CASKEY. THE SALES WORLD
FOR. AS A. YEAH
. YEAH. THIS IS
A SIMPLY BILL EIGHTEEN TEN BY
THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON
TRANSPORTATION MEASURE THE
MOTION IS AT THE MEASURE BE
RETURNED TO THE SENATE FLOOR
FOR CONSIDERATION DOLLING DOT.
DOT I AM GALGIANI. CASTING
CANCER. ONE OPEN FOR ONE MINUTE
TEN SECONDS. BACK IN TWO
. WILL
TURN